the owner of the Dallas Cowboys Jerry
Jones Jerry how are you buddy Michael
man it's good talking to you and I've
got a hoarse throat of all things
talking to you last time I talked to you
you were a little hoarse and I am so
happy to be on the show talking with you
today just so the listeners are
understand I was talking to Michael
while he was up there in the hospital
here about a month ago
getting some dicey information back from
his checkup so buddy I love you and I
love you too Jerry I appreciate that
phone call man and all of the support
and while you bring that up let me let
me tell everybody out there for all the
prayers and everything in that tough
moment and and maybe I'll talk about
some of that probably tomorrow before I
leave
I want to tell them thank you for all
their prayers and everything because
that was a dicey moment but Jerry you
guys just went through the draft you
didn't have a first round because of the
Amari Cooper Trey but talk to me about
your thoughts on how you think that
draft went for your Dallas Cowboys well
first of all you take the fake out of me
there's not much left and what does that
mean it means I can live a little bit in
a fantasy or I can live a little bit in
my dreams and so I didn't have any
trouble picturing Amari making running
those routes and getting open and that
as I sit there in that draft room going
to really that first night and most of
the second day and without a draft pick
but I'll tell you what when you're at
the bottom of the draft and you've given
up your number one pick that is a long
old wait but to get right to it
Tristan Hill is a player that we had
really hoped would make it to us some
say we took him too high but our hope
was that he would get to us we knew that
one issue that caused him to
have a real quick critical look was the
fact that his last year there at Central
Florida was mixed with was a mixed
review because he really didn't play
that much yet he was physically able to
play that gave us this opportunity
because he is the prototype interior
lineman for what we want and that
position is critical he disrupts he gets
into the backfield quickly that
disturbing to whatever the offense has
in mind
it's his forte he's got the size and so
we really got our fix big-time when
Tristan Hill was still there and we were
able to draft him with that 58 to pick
in the draft Jerry you know it's
interesting as I watch the last few
years here you guys have put such a
focus I mean more so than early on in
your career and owning of Dallas Cowboys
the focus has been on offense and
defensive lines what changed over the
years that you guys have turned that
focus towards that offensive defensive
line with the draft well as it turns out
we've had opportunity there
Tristan hill that was manifest itself
because of the fact that we didn't have
that first pick and the fact that we're
running the system that we're running
but I mean you know I think at the end
of the day with the defense's hell-bent
on creating pressure disrupting I think
that's across the board then we wanted a
protection there for Romo when Romo was
here
and now then dak is taking advantage of
it but we wanted protection and
protection comes not only in the form of
blocking them out and keeping them from
actually physically getting to the
quarterback protection comes from being
able to provide a threat in the running
game because it's real hard for those
defenses to really pin their ears back
and rush at the same time defend against
the running game that's challenging and
so that offensive line does two things
for you it helps your running game it
helps your protection
that's the way we've built this team and
candidly we've seen it work now we
haven't seen it work to the extent that
we've been in a Super Bowl but we do
know that those fronts and plus we like
our numbers no matter how you set it up
last year there we were kind of feeling
like we had it kind of pinned in and
there Fredrik our Center comes down with
a very unplanned syndrome that really
set us back it gave us an opportunity to
see a couple of pretty good football
players that played in his good stead
when we didn't have him but still it
shows you the need for depth and the
offensive line shows you the need for
rotation try to keep as fresh as you can
on the defensive line until you talked
about it it's Jerry Jones on the Rich
Eisen show I am guest hosting Michael
Irvin here guess hos Michael Irvin Jerry
you talked about protection and and what
that offensive line protects and your
offensive line all of that investment
that you have put into it is protecting
that Prescott when you see what
quarterbacks are signing for now with
Russell Wilson just signing the biggest
contract by about by a quarterback in
NFL history what are your thoughts to
trying to lock up dak Prescott for the
long term oh I think that we're sold on
that and we do want to have him for the
long term we think he's worthy of
investing in for the long term that he's
going into his fourth year now in the
NFL when you look at the snaps he's had
when you look at the situations he's
been in when you look at first of all
how he got here and then you see
but really how he has performed but you
also we see real upside in that you
don't have it all yet and we love the
way that he I'm gonna use the word
logically progresses through a game you
seem when the going gets tough or you
see when he's got to come from behind
when he kind of turns it loose a little
bit you seen make those plays all of
those things Imboden made to make a deal
with him that puts him here with the
Cowboys for the long term but Jerry this
Jerry Jones owner the Dallas Cowboys
here on the Rich Eisen show I guess host
microwave and for Rich Eisen Jerry you
said you guys in for the long haul and
that gives you're a guy but does that
mean you are willing to make that the
new highest paid quarterback in the NFL
how have you had those conversations
Michael are you sitting here and
negotiating you know I've had enough
rounds of negotiating with you I refuse
to go back in that room I refused to go
sit through it out of year hey Michael
came in justifiably so and he was
representing himself for all practical
purposes but he had really some
qualified people that were representing
us but frankly nobody bought qualified
than Michaels so boy comes in the office
and we were negotiating his last
contract that we did with the Cowboys
and he deserved a big contract and man
he had it all lined out there and it was
no smiles it was going over well he was
sitting in the same chair and in the
same office where no two men have cried
together anymore and laugh together
anymore than we have
some moments in the more fat valleys for
both sides of the equation here's an
mind well anyway we're sitting there and
we're going over it and he said yeah it
just looks to me like here's where we
ought to be and so I look over at
Michael and I say Michael there's an Old
West Texas town down there of the
Mexican border it's called El Paso I not
many jobs offering that kind of money
outside what we were doing in that
office area and I found it so funny
Jerry does a great job of lightening the
mood when it when the most pressure is
on in a negotiation and I know that work
with me Jerry but but how is that going
to play out with Jack and his people now
you know is it we're at a different time
now quarterback sir I mean just just
getting paid out of hand money I believe
I think so I think you're given all the
credit to quarterback so how are you
going to handle that negotiation knowing
you got Z coming up after that and Amari
Cooper coming up after that well first
of all I've got to have I've got to go
down by all Paso on some of those offers
they go put in front of you no seriously
I'm confident we'll get this done up and
I do not have a you know in a in a
proposition there's a lot of things that
go into it now the money the money is
very important you know I'm a Salesman
and there are five things that make a
great salesman one asked for the money I
forgot the other four that's what makes
you great
great sales with balls they ask about
the team also do you know and coach
Garrett you know the last few years
certainly had you in the playoffs won
the division last season and and and we
do all of it I mean what are your
thoughts on this year's cowboys and and
is there anything or any any place that
you think that Coach Garrett has to get
the Cowboys this year well I think that
it's legitimate it's it's being noted
that we're in the last year of Jason's
contracts he's been there before and his
last year it's obvious to the world that
Jason as Bill Parcells you say might
have a place in the family portrait as
far as how valued he is Jason is out
outstanding today relative to where he
was when he joined our team as a coach
offensive coordinator and then became
the head coach but what has happened is
on our dime so to speak on our fans on
our team
Jason has become outstanding and so my
complete rationale and my complete goal
is now that he's evolved to the level
that he is he always had all of the
background his dad was a great NFL man
and he grew up around the kitchen table
listening to being in the NFL and then
he has a bob and he didn't go to
Princeton because he couldn't pass as
SAT test for sure
so he's smart he's articulate and we've
won a lot of ballgames and actually I
think he's the second when it's
percentage coach in the history of the
Dallas Cowboys you know I spent some
time
my point is we're we've got I'm
satisfied with where we are with his
contract
right now it is to be negotiated at some
point in the future and we all know that
we need to get out in when ball games
and speaking of winning ball games and
speaking of smart I spent some time you
know this weekend with Ezekiel Elliott
Jerry and I I scratched my head when it
went down and this is microwave and I'm
guest hosting for Rich Eisen on the Rich
Eisen show and speaking with Dallas
Cowboys owner Jerry Jones I scratch my
head when when the hire was made when
you gave Kelly Moore the offensive
coordinators job but I will say this and
I want to get your thoughts on it after
speaking this weekend with Ezekiel
Elliott I kind of did a 360 a 180 on it
I should say because what anything Zeke
said he said Michael no this kid is
smart he said he's smart and I think the
most important thing he said I want to
hear your thoughts on this
he said he'll listen to us what we see
on the field he'll listen and
incorporate it in the game plan your
thoughts on hiring Kellen Moore and
actually hearing and did you hear from
guys like Zeke and did that play into
your decision well one of the things we
know for sure is we've got a young
coaching staff Jason himself is a
relatively young Jason Garrett
relatively young man but the point is
that in telling we sure have a young
coach so you know I'm not paying for
we're not getting experience here we're
not getting that so what are you getting
if you're not getting experience how
about that how about that part of the
makeup of a man or a woman that hasn't
been told no all their life they don't
know that they can't do it there is an
unbridled enthusiasm
Michael you you were are such a part of
that when you go into a proposition and
you were for the Dallas Cowboys all of
your teammates have always said there's
one guy that we couldn't have done it
without and that was
michael irvin that had everything to do
with that you exude it and believed that
you could do it and it was just a
question of getting it figured out kelan
is very articulate
he has a great way of explaining his
thoughts and his ideas exceptional and
I'm a big communications guy and it
doesn't always not always articulated
verbally can be done with body language
it can be done with the looks and eyes
but he is outstanding no matter where
you turn to they'll give you a big grade
on him by being a great communicator
very articulate with and that is
listening as well as as well as
expressing your ideas so I think I think
we really start out with a plus right
there he has certainly experience
working with everybody that he's going
to be working with here and I think this
will be a big plus it's important that
to me that Jason Garrard is if you will
sitting here as a safety net relative to
the nuts and bolts of the offense
he certainly has been around offensive
all of his career and certainly around
cowboy offensive all of his career but
he can be a great safety net and so it
was a great opportunity
from my perspective to take a unproven
if you will a young Kellen Moore
surround him with really fresh ideas
surround him with a team that has worked
with him like worked in the locker room
with him as a fellow player many of them
have and then let them come together
with the idea that as a safety net
you've got a seasoned offensive mind
that can sit there as we go into the
season and as we execute basically be
there in case a wheel comes off I looked
at that as great opportunity yeah and
and and and I'm anxious to see exactly
how that plays out with all of those new
thoughts and new tricks and that he will
bring to the office Jerry think thanks
for taking the time I know you're busy
of taking the time out to call answer
the Rich Eisen show here and give us a
moment of your time buddy Michael you've
come a long way to be substituting for
the great rich ices proud to be on the
show and proud that you're doing the
work today
I appreciate it boss appreciate it man I
love you boss thanks man that is that is
the man right there you just say what
you we are now for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on Direct TV for free on be our live or
download the Rich Eisen show app